y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniela blandón daniela
buena noche bienvenida el desempleo en
eeuu bajó en el mes de febrero hola raúl
buenas noches de mire antes de la
pandemia la tasa de desocupación en eeuu
estaba en 3,5 por ciento ahora quedó
prácticamente estable en 62 por ciento
la más baja desde que inició la pandemia
llegó a dispararse hasta el 14 7 la
sorpresa vino por el lado de la creación
de plazas laborales que en febrero fue
de 379 mil cuando en el peor momento se
perdieron más de 20 millones de empleos
en un solo mes sumando y restando raúl
cada mes al final se tiene que de los 22
como de 2 millones de puestos de trabajo
perdidos en la crisis unos 12,7 millones
ya se han recuperado el presidente job
aiden reaccionó con un llamado a aprobar
un nuevo plan de estímulos a parte del
crecimiento del empleo del mes pasado es
el resultado del paquete de ayuda de
diciembre pero sin un plan de rescate
estos avances se realizan
no podemos dar un paso adelante y dos
atrás dalier en otras noticias bruselas
y washington hacen las paces pero
temporalmente la casa blanca lleva casi
dos décadas de pelea con este grupo de
países se acusan mutuamente de dar
subsidios ilegales a sus gigantes
aeronáuticos boeing y hervás como parte
de la pelea se han impuesto aranceles
millonarios en los últimos años hace
apenas un día a londres y washington
anunciaron una tregua y ahora lo hace la
unión europea de la que reinó unido- ya
no es parte por cuarto por cuatro meses
ya no habrá aranceles sobre productos
que al año representan unos 11.500
millones de dólares los grandes
beneficiados por el lado europeo son en
raúl desde los aviones y repuestos hasta
vinos y mermeladas de francia- aceitunas
españolas licores y quesos
daniela y el precio del petróleo llega a
su mejor nivel en un año la referencia
de doblete y están 66 dólares algo no
visto desde abril de 2019 mientras que
el pendiente está casi en 70 dólares su
máximo valor desde enero de 2000
este repunte se debe a que la opep más
que es el grupo de países exportadores
más rusia decidió esta semana mantener
sus recortes de producción ambas
referencias son bastante utilizadas en
américa latina'
por eso el buen precio les conviene a
los grandes productores de la región
como lo son méxico brasil venezuela
colombia y argentina-ecuador por ejemplo
que no producen mucho petróleo su
economía si depende de estas divisas
vamos a ver con una paradoja daniela en
cuba- y oficios que persisten gracias a
la escasez crónica
raúl el coronavirus lo que ha hecho es
agravar la crisis de desabastecimiento
intermitente que por décadas ha azotado
al país caribe por eso para muchos
habitantes reponer lo que se gasta o se
rompe simplemente no es una opción hay
un sinfín de artículos que en otros
lugares serían desechados pero que en
cuba reciben una segunda oportunidad por
eso existen los rellenadores de
encendedores los limpiadores de ollas o
reparadores de paraguas y anteojos pero
dejemos que sean ellos mismos quienes
nos expliquen qué es lo que hacen raúl a
y los rellenos reparo
llevado de todo aquí
a la piedra el cambio las piedras y
reparos con flor era llevado de todo
todo lo que tiene que ver con una
costurera que después que le damos la
candela el agua fría el encantado de
haberle la claridad y de ahí pasa la
máquina donde le damos el pulido no
llegamos ya ya tú le pones aquí y puede
darle candela tres días en los 870 pero
no pone de las modernas horas y se
derrita en el momento daniela
indicadores como cierran las bolsas y al
final de la semana trabó la bolsa de
nueva york despide una semana de
altibajos marcada hoy justamente por el
informe de empleos
las bolsas europeas bajaron a pesar de
estos datos de eeuu que fueron
considerados alentadores y en américa
latina hubo resultados dispares caída de
más del 1 por ciento en buenos aires
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día 11,5 millones de dólares de raúl
en esto fue subastado esta semana en
londres un cuadro de un paisaje marroquí
que pintó a nadie más y nada menos que
winston churchill este fue un regalo del
líder británico de la segunda guerra
mundial le hizo al entonces presidente
de estados
franklin roosevelt el precio pagado por
el cuadro que estaba en poder de
angelina jolie es hasta ahora el más
alto pagado por una obra del ex primer
ministro británico raoul y así anhela
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información económica ustedes también
gracias continúan con nosotros
buena noche